Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
I am your host Rawkode.
Before we get started, here's a quick reminder
that you should subscribe to my channel at
Rawkode live and click that bell. That means
you're gonna get all of the updates and
there are multiple streams per week. So hopefully
there is content there. We can all continue
to learn this vast cloud native landscape.
Also be aware that we do have a
discord chat. Please come and join us. The
conversation is always fun and there's lots to
learn from everyone involved there too. So cool.
Get involved. Now today we are gonna take,
we're gonna attempt to write a Kubernetes controller
to satisfy a random idea that I had
in December last We'll talk a little bit
about that in just a moment.
But I am not smart enough to write
my own Kubernetes controller so I have solicited
some help from a friend of mine, Sahil
Patel. Hey man. How are you doing?
Hello.
Great to be joining you. Thank you for
the invite.
Yeah. This will be fun.
Hold on. Too many buttons. There we go.
Yeah. I'm really looking forward to this.
I have written Kubernetes controllers before. I think
you've got way more experience than me here.
So So maybe we can, we'll do introductions
first, but you know, maybe we'll talk a
little bit about the different ways to extend
and modify Kubernetes and get people a little
bit of insight
and flavor into how that works.
So let's start first with you. Why don't
you give us the Sahil pitch?
Hey.
Thank you. Hi. My name is Sahil.
I am a software engineer. Currently, I work
for a company called Monza,
where I help build a better banking experience.
I've been using Kubernetes for a number of
years now and been involved with the CNCF
ecosystems
of software. So things like Prometheus,
Jaeger,
and all of these other tools, Kubernetes,
Envoy proxy, and all of the other tools
that are involved in the CNCF ecosystem.
And yeah,
essentially,
I want to make infrastructure
like, want to represent infrastructure from an end
user perspective.
So like getting involved from within the end
user community and stuff like that.
Awesome. Very cool.
All right. So Kubernetes controllers.
What are they?
So think of a Kubernetes controller in the
sense that you use with Kubernetes, you declare
what you want, and the Kubernetes controller
does all the actions necessary
to take what you want done
and actually
make that reality.
So essentially,
if you create a deployment
in Kubernetes, you specify lots of YAML.
And you might specify like a deployment object.
It will take that, and it will then
essentially
process that, see the state of the current
cluster to see, for example, if that object
already exists with that particular name. It
takes what you desire
and
gets it to the end state. So for
example, in a deployment, it will take
the number of replicas. It will create the
replica set if necessary.
It will pull down the image,
and it will create the required pods.
It will do everything that is necessary
to satisfy
what you declare essentially.
Alright. And
I mean, is it fair to say that
everything in Kubernetes is a controller as it
is just now?
Pretty much everything. Yeah. Like, you know, a
lot of the common objects that you interact
with such as deployments,
replica sets,
all of these standard Kubernetes objects are essentially
controllers.
And they're getting down to the lowest
level Kubernetes
abstractions,
which is things
like pods and containers
to the very end. So essentially everything is
like layers of manipulation between
to get to a state where you have
pods and containers running in your cluster.
Okay, cool. Very cool.
All right, we have a couple of comments
so let's get them on the screen and
then why don't you and I just talk
about the problem that we want to solve
today and then we'll talk about the different
ways that we could potentially achieve
that then. So Vignesh welcome back,
hello
We have a excited.
Yep. I am excited too. That's for sure.
And a hi from Moz. Hey, hi Moz.
Not sure why that font is a colored
black. I'll fix that later.
Okay. So
when we chatted about doing this we had
rough idea that
what if let
me throw this back. I wish I'd
had the foresight to find this tweet and
maybe I'll try and find that in a
second but I think it was in December
I tweeted
an image
where I had
taken
I had taken the image tag within a
pod spec and made it look a little
bit weird. What I did was put the
image name and then for the tag
I actually provided like a semantic version constraint.
Maybe that's best visualized actually.
Let me pull up my screen share.
Assume this was a pod
and then the image nginx and
I think what I had was like
greater than that's a more Versus code. Something
like this.
Where
it's not valid and that this is not
a correct image
name or tag
and
this has no semantic meaning within a Kubernetes
cluster. There's no way to really tell what
this means. There's no way to really
I mean, this would just fail. Right?
Yeah. Because I wouldn't be able to pull
it back. So what if we could write
something and the Kubernetes land
that would notice
this unique syntax for the image and then
resolve that for us at runtime
and update our pod spec.
That makes sense?
Yeah, absolutely.
So this was quite interesting because
from this tweet, I actually gave this a
shot to see how far you could get,
you know, whether even Kubernetes will accept this
as like valid input. It does. You put
this into your YAML. It does, yeah. I
was quite surprised. I thought it would immediately
complain
because it's not a valid image name.
But because it does accept it, that means
it is storing that somewhere. So it's storing
that state in
the Kubernetes storage
system in etcd.
So for example,
we can then
essentially extract that and manipulate it to convert
it into something
that is usable and that will essentially resolve
and run on our cluster.
Yeah.
So there is there more than one way
for us to make this work?
Yeah. There's actually a multitude of ways.
So
what we could do, for example, is we
could say that we want to go completely
custom, and we want to write a custom
controller
that will look like a deployment. For example,
we might give it a a kind of
like a version deployment
and, you know, that would take the or
like a versioned pod, for example,
that would look exactly like a pod spec
but would manipulate the image field before essentially
interacting with the version pod controller and converting
that versioned
image name, like what you specified here, into
a concrete image version and then pass it
off to a pod to continue its pod
lifecycle.
Now
another
way, and I think the way we might
possibly want to explore in this session,
is Kubernetes
provides
two kinds of hooks
when objects are created and when pods are
being built.
Actually, this works for any API object, I
believe.
You have
mutation
controllers and you have validation controllers.
So go into validation controls first. Validation controls
are pretty much like what they sound. Essentially,
you can provide a completely valid Kubernetes pod
spec or deployment spec or any sort of
spec. And you might want to validate it
in some ways. So for example, you may
want to look at the state of your
cluster and say, oh, we should only be
running
this many deployments with this particular label. Or
this particular deployment is valid, but it's missing
this particular annotation,
for example.
And you might want to validate that and
deny
that resource from being created.
So for example,
when you create a
pod spec
and you add something that is invalid using
kubectl,
essentially you will get like a denied
error
if you write something invalid. That's essentially the
validation
kicking in.
The other thing that you can do is
essentially like a mutation
controller. So mutation controller,
actually, it'd be quite good if we pull
up
the documentation on this. So if you could
pull up maybe the admission controllers
for Kubernetes.
Yeah, that one. Yeah, that one is fine.
So essentially both mutation and validation
controllers are types of admission controllers.
And
what a mutation controller allows us to do
is essentially
hook into
an object that's being created as part of
the creation lifecycle and apply patches, apply mutations.
So similar to how you can do kubectl
patch, you can do that add creation
time
dynamically.
And the way that they've implemented that in
this particular controller,
in this particular admission controller, is allowing
for like a webhook style system.
So essentially every time a pod or a
deployment or something, whatever object you want to
watch for gets created,
It will essentially call into a custom webhook
that we can specify.
And then we can then mutate the output
and add
anything we want or tweak anything we want
before it goes on to the rest of
the pod or deployment or replica set creation
lifecycle.
Awesome.
The good news is I also found my
tweet.
There we go.
This is my bold idea. November 13, if
I have a search in December, this was
wrong.
But we're gonna try and make something like
this work.
So that was a really great explanation of
validating
webhooks and mutating webhooks.
I think you know, there's a lot of
flexibility, lot of power just in those two
methods have been able to extend Kubernetes without
you know, getting into the nitty gritty of
actually like writing a you know, a controller
with a loop and reconciliation and ownership of
CRDs and all that stuff like you know,
you just maybe you just want to extend
like we want to today.
A primitive that already exists like a pod
and we can do a cool couple of
tweaks there. So is it fair to say
that at a really naive level that these
are just simple functions that take an HTTP
request out and then spit something back out?
That's exactly it. Yeah. Essentially
right now I believe admission controllers only
give you the the object as JSON,
and you will read the object as JSON.
And,
you know, you can use the Kubernetes
core v one to unmarshal
all the JSON that's provided to you. And
you quite literally write,
like if you've used customize or anything similar,
you essentially write a Kubernetes patch. So you'll
have like an operation.
You'll have a path. And you'll have a
value. And essentially you specify a series of
patches that you want to run.
And
can specify no patches, for example. You could
just say
the same thing that's come in is the
same thing that's going out,
for example.
And yeah essentially
that webhook is essentially just ferrying some patches
which would then be applied
as part of the mutations and then it
will go on to the rest of the
life cycle.
Okay.
So is that our first step then is
that we wanna write some
go application that we can deploy to our
cluster register as a web hook, validating or
mutating
and just take on a request and just
pass it on. That's
step one right?
Yeah exactly.
So yeah,
it's
pretty much exactly as you described.
We're going to write a really simple Go
application,
a Go binary, and get that deployed. And
it gets deployed in the cluster just like
any other
deployment would. So we're going to create a
Kubernetes deployment.
You can run it with multiple replicas.
You know, it will have a service backing
it
and yeah,
that's basically it. Awesome. I love how you
say we. I feel that you're just taking
pity on me because you know, I'm gonna
be leaning on you an awful lot for
today's session. So
let's get started then,
we have a Versus Code live share set
up, we both have the ability to pair
program on this and type code.
I'm assuming we're gonna wanna just initialize a
really simple Go repository,
pull in client Go that we'll probably need
later and then build a Docker image.
I'm guessing feel free to just tell me
I'm wrong and that's not the first step.
No, no. I think that sounds really really
reasonable.
Essentially we'll get,
it'll allow us to like interact with all
the different things that are involved
and like talk a little bit about the
prerequisites before we get into the really,
really
like quite finicky stuff of getting the actual
webhook installed into Kubernetes itself towards
the end hopefully.
So yeah,
let's start it with some code. Well we
also have a question. Are you ready? Because
this
I wonder if you've got opinions on this.
Go for Mozz has asked, what are the
differences between a controller and an operator?
I see an operator as acting on top
of a custom resource. So for example, I
would write an operator if I want to
interact with something
outside of the Kubernetes
ecosystem. So for example, if I wanted to
tap in to
a Cassandra cluster and cleanly shut it down
as part of let's say that I got
an event that's saying that a pod is
about to be terminated, and I wanted to
cleanly shut it down and reconcile that with
my Cassandra cluster, I would term that as
an operator.
Essentially, it's like extending the Kubernetes lifecycle
to do things with especially stateful infrastructure, for
example.
With the controller itself,
it's more
taking and interacting with your Kubernetes system itself.
So essentially, it's taking
something that you want done in Kubernetes and
using Kubernetes as a way of making that
happen. So I would typically have a controller
interacting with
standard Kubernetes objects, deployments,
replica sets, pods, secrets, config maps,
essentially
describing those primitives.
A
controller and operator under the hood are very
similar things. You're going to have one loop.
You're going to be checking for mutations.
You're going have like a Kubernetes watcher
at some point, maybe listening for events.
So in
implementation,
they might look quite similar.
But I think it's just a matter of
terminology.
And to be honest it is personal preference
like depending
on what you read, where you go,
the terminologies are really mixed up.
Okay,
first I just wanna point out that see
your ability to answer and explain stuff is
phenomenal.
So thank you very much.
Secondly, would you, I'm gonna throw a statement
out there. Would you say that all operators
are controllers but not all controllers are operators?
Does that pass?
All operators are controllers but not all controllers
are operators.
Yeah, I think would agree with that. You
see the thing is in an operator,
there's no reason why an operator again, taking,
for example, the Cassandra
example there. There's no reason why the Cassandra
operator
can't
interact with both the Kubernetes ecosystem
itself.
Whereas if you're writing a controller,
I would probably want to scope it to
just the Kubernetes
aspect itself
and leave the actual management of third party
infrastructure to something like an operator.
Yeah. Awesome.
Alright. We'll tackle one more question there. Fair
coming in today. And then we will actually
write some codes. So Sachin has asked, is
there any difference between writing controls from
versus using tools like cube builder, operator framework,
etcetera?
That's a really good question.
So
with the pre generated
code that you get, it comes with a
lot of niceties out of the box.
It writes a lot of the boilerplate for
you.
It gets you started on a really nice
layer.
It gives you all the dependencies you need.
It gives you some boilerplate YAML that you
can start applying to cluster.
Actually, later on when we're writing this mutating
webhook,
it's going to be really interesting to go
through the Kubernetes phase because there's so many
finicky things that you need to do in
order to get these
mutating webhooks hooks running.
So
and you know all of these things are
not extremely well documented.
Know so
the
interesting love when you generate
something using like the operator framework that might
be the best source of documentation
for running a Kubernetes controller.
Know, because essentially that is part of the
Kubernetes project and they expect
others to not go it alone.
Essentially they expect everyone to be using that
sort of framework.
Alright.
Would it be fair to say that you
only need to use cube builder operator SDK
all these other tools when you're registered like
I always think of them as being tools
that simplify
you know creating the CRDs applying them to
the cluster providing the ownership like when you're
working at that level it would make sense
to use one of these tools but for
today's example where we're doing you know a
web hook that mutates an existing spec that
you don't particularly need those tools.
Yeah that's that's exactly and also I think
by doing it from scratch it's a nice
way to understand how all the pieces fit
together.
You know all the pieces you need and
also
I also want to demonstrate hopefully,
especially
the code side, it doesn't need to be
that complicated.
Hopefully,
we'll have to see how we get on.
Hopefully, lot of the primitives look familiar to
like anyone who's written Go before
and maybe not played around too much with
the Kubernetes SDK side of things.
Okay.
Great.
There's lots of context there, lots of knowledge.
I hope everyone is enjoying the session. I
think we just dive straight on now. We
start getting some code together.
If you're watching and you have more questions,
please leave them in the chat. We will
do our best to answer them as we
go.
Alright,
let's do this.
I'm gonna assume we just need to run
a go mod in here.
Yeah, that's right. We're going to need to
pull in the Go SDK at some point.
I've created a main. Go.
So yeah, we're going start with a package
main.
Essentially, what we're going to have is we're
going to have a HTTP
server
listening on TLS. So a mutating webhook
or any sort of webhook that interacts with
Kubernetes
doesn't interact
over a non TLS connection.
So we're going to have to do some
certificate
faff a little bit later on.
But we are going to be listening on
a TLS connection.
Now, as I say that, I have realized
that we will also need
some keys at some point. So for now,
I imagine we're going to hard bake some
paths and then we can inject those in
as a Kubernetes
secret
later on when we're setting up the Kubernetes
side of things.
Yes definitely.
Okay so
Mars has given us some moral support here.
Let's do it. Thank you.
Now
this is just we're just gonna use net
issue to be ready from the go standard
library so I mean I'm not gonna remember
how to type that off the top of
my head I'm gonna assume you probably may
be able to type off the top of
your head but we're just gonna grab that
from Google
Yeah.
I'm gonna go for the time. You're gonna
go for it. Right? Yeah. I'm gonna go
for it. Let let's see how much I
can remember.
So
essentially, we're gonna need http.handleFunc,
I believe.
And essentially,
what that's going to look at is
we're going to have a mutate endpoint.
And that's going to
call into a handle mutate function. Is that
mutate endpoint convention
or explicit?
You
can specify it in your YAML,
but it is convention.
Yeah. It is just what all the mutating
webhooks
seem to be using.
So this is gonna be a
response writer,
and
we're going to have a HTTP
request
here.
Hopefully, I got the order of that right.
Value of type func.
Oh, sorry. I think I just want to
handle.
And
we're going to have
a HTTP
listen and serve
TLS.
Have listen on port four forty three.
And that's a
cert.
Server
oh, sorry, webhook.cert.
And
webhookkey.pem
at some point. So we're going to have
to inject those in as a Kubernetes secret.
I wonder why this is
not liking.
I believe we do need a handle function.
Is that correct?
Hold
on. If I get the other complete, I'll
just show people let's say pattern and handler
was accepted here.
So let's see.
What's the error message?
I think I've got in the pointers the
wrong way around.
Cannot use handle mutate
value of func blah blah blah as we
should be handler value and argumentation handler message
server
HTTP.
I
had the pointers
of the arguments the wrong way around. The
HTTP response writer is
just a standard struct and the HTTP request
is pointer.
Sounds me right for not Googling.
Cool.
Now what we get in,
if maybe we quickly pull up the documentation
for
an admission
controller.
So
if you maybe search for admission review, maybe
it's on this page.
Nope.
No.
That's the admission review.
We just want that struct. Right? So Yeah.
That's That's right.
There we are. Oh, actually, that's perfect. So
webhooks are sent a post request with content
type application JSON,
and it has an admission review API object
in the admission.case.io
API group.
So essentially, that's what we're going to be
getting in.
And as a response, we'll also be sending
back out and it says later on in
the page an admission review
response. So admission review has
oddly
non Go standardness. It has an admission review
and then a request inside it. And it
also has the response inside it as well.
So we'll get an admission review, and we'll
send back an admission review. So let's write
a really, really simple one
where we're just taking in the admission review
and marshaling it,
and then
just spitting the same admission review back out.
And in order to do this, we're going
to need the
API
sorry, the K8s API. So if we do
go get. Uk8s.io
API,
That would download the latest API and also
put it in our Go mod. And that
should be ready for use now.
So
if we have input
as
admission
v one,
review,
this is the struct we're gonna drop into.
Let's see if the PLS more like this.
Admission v one is
case.io
slash API
admission v one, which is where the
actual admission lies.
I think that's just resolving on my end.
So while it's resolving,
I will continue coding.
So essentially, what we want to do
is we want to
decode
body
that we get from
the request into this admission review.
So that's going to be auto body
and decode
review.
For
all my girlfriends that are watching, we're gonna
be quite liberal with the errors that come
out of this. We're just gonna send them
back out.
Interestingly,
what you can do is
within the when you're writing an admission controller,
if it does return an error,
you can specify as part of your mutating
webhook whether you want the admission to fail
because it couldn't resolve or to ignore. So
essentially to just continue on with no mutations
being applied from the mutating webhook.
So when we initially set it up, we're
probably going set it to ignore level because
we're testing around.
But then we may switch that to a
more stricter policy of
failing if it encounters any errors.
So I'm just gonna define maybe a send
error function,
which is gonna take an error.
And what that's going to do is
that's also going to take our
response writer as well.
Writer.
We want to
send back content type
application JSON.
And
we also want to
send back a status code.
Think the autocomplete
has
sort of broken
internal server error. That's alright. I'll just continue
to type while it catches up.
And
we also want to marshal the error at
some point.
So
Marshall
match.
I think this compiler caught up, so
hopefully you have your auto complete back.
Oh.
Although it keeps saying add our loading workspace.
Okay. So go some needed disabled by mod
read only. Alright. Okay. Go mod's just about
unhappy. We'll try and fix it when you're
you're ready.
Cool.
So what I've done here is I have
output that error,
And there's not much we can do if
we're already in the process of sending an
error and we have an error whilst we're
trying to encode the error.
So hopefully that will succeed all the time.
And we want to write that out. And
we are done there.
Let's see.
I probably needed to download all the dependencies.
Yeah. Hopefully that keeps it happy.
Undefined JSON.
Undefined JSON. Yeah. So we probably didn't import
that. Thank you. And
I think we're missing
our listen and serve
String
string string handler.
We need to specify a handler. Well, I
think I might need to wrap this in
a in a serve mux.
We
need
a server.
HTTP
server.
Free.
Handler
is going to be Linux.
And then
serve this and then serve PLS.
And just specify the port because that's in
the address.
I've got a saving main dot go here.
I imagine that's not saved yet.
Can
include actions from Go. Thanks to s code.
Very helpful.
I'm not sure what it's
Oh, okay. I think that just saved. So
It says we have string string string and
I want string string string handler.
Yeah. But we don't have http.listen
and serve t l s anymore.
So
I wonder if it's even reading that code.
Let's have a look. Main.go.
Yeah. So it's still got our old code
there.
Don't think Versus code has saved that.
Let's see what is this saying.
Cancel.
Let's try just maybe it's just unhappy because
it's trying to run something. Let's make sure
we have our dependencies.
Save.
There we go.
Okay.
So we got package
JSON.
That's
good.
Does it need to be encoding JSON?
Yeah.
Think you're right.
Am I am I on that line?
If you just add encoding slash JSON.
There we are.
Sweet.
Let's give that a build.
Okay. We're closer.
We're getting there. Not enough arguments in call
for HTTP error. That's line number 22.
Ah, cool. Okay. So that's just on our
error line here.
So essentially,
what we want there is we also need
to specify specify the
oh, the return code.
Status
internal
sub error.
Yeah. That should work. What else was around?
Handle mutate. It's got a few bugs here.
Yes. Okay. Cool. So
that should not be reviewed. That should be
input.
And if
does not equal mail, send.
Response writer.
To the people watching, we'll we'll go over
all this in a moment once we get
it compelling.
Yes. Yes.
Could not on Marshall.
Ricky
says, I can't believe there's someone who can
code without ID auto complete.
Yes. It's not me. I'm glad it's a
hail that's for sure and I would have
copy and pasted all of that http handle
stuff. You were very brave there.
Or silly, who knows we'll find out. Yeah,
I think I think it's probably the latter
there.
Brave I think is a is a a
I think it's giving me too much credit.
You
did well you were pulling that at the
top of your head and it's even compiling
now so. Oh wow.
Amazing.
Alright so
Let's just take
one minute
to
go through this talk about what's actually happening.
Know it's mostly boilerplate I think that's should
be encouraging for people we've not actually done
anything yet. This is literally code you could
if it works copy and paste and use
it for all of your admission controllers.
So I'll
let you just take a wee bit of
time to run through this since it's your
code.
Yeah absolutely. So starting at the at the
bottom there into our main function, that's going
to be our entry point And essentially, what
we're saying there is
we've defined one
endpoint, the mutate endpoint.
And that's going to call into the handle
mutate function there.
We're listening on port four forty three. That
will listen on local host. So we need
to set up the container port forwarding in
our Kubernetes
manifest.
And essentially,
we are setting up a TLS
server.
So what Go will do under the hood
is it will set up a TLS wrapped
HTTP server. So it will do all the
TLS validation
for us,
everything that is necessary.
We probably
wrap this in a log. Fatal,
just if it quits for whatever reason. And
this will essentially block.
So it will continue listening forever.
And I've just wrapped it in a log
dot fatal to print out any errors if
it exits uncleanly.
Yeah. So that's our main function there.
If we scroll up a little,
we've defined a
mutate handler,
a HTTP handler,
that takes in the two traditional arguments for
every HTTP handler, which is a writer and
the request.
Oddly the request doesn't come first as an
argument. If I was
the implementer of this I'd put the request
first just because that's how I think about
it. Request then response.
But here you get it the other way
around.
So yeah you have
just a standard HTTP
Go boilerplate function, which is taken in our
request. The actual payload itself is in the
body. So we have R. Body.
And essentially, we need to write out any
sort of response to the ResponseWriter.
Now ResponseWriter
is quite literally an IO buffer under the
hood. So
if you were using Netcat or something like
that,
you would have to send out your response
in the same order. So you need to
write the
status code.
You need to write any
headers
that you need to write first. And then
you write out your payload
in the end.
All right.
Now I guess I have a question. In
our handle mutate function, we're not returning anything?
Yeah, that's right. So the
handler has no mutation arguments.
Sorry, it has no return arguments.
You know, it doesn't return anything like an
error or anything like that.
Think about it from Go perspective. If a
Go is serving a HTTP request,
within the boundaries of that particular function, anything
that could error,
you know, would have to be like a
panic level error, like where the entire program
just crashes.
Otherwise,
all the other errors are meant to be
handled in the request response lifecycle.
So for example, if you encounter any sort
of logical error with the request that comes
in,
we've written a boilerplate function to send out
an error. Because we'll be using this quite
often
throughout
the handling of the
mutation itself.
Especially
when we're encoding things back and forth, there's
always places where things could fail. And in
Go, it's good practice to always handle the
errors as soon as they come in
and not ignore them
unlike
Java where you just have like a big
try catch block.
Okay. Could we
just explain like, okay, so if there's multiple
admission controllers registered with our Kubernetes API server,
you know, and we're one of many.
How do those interact with each other? How
are they modifying the request? Is there
ordering? Is there priorities?
How how does that work?
That's a really good question. The
ordering of admission controllers
is well defined
like for within Kubernetes itself. I'm not quite
sure how
ordering works if you have multiple mutation controllers
and if there is any preferred ordering.
So I may need to look that one
up. I'm not sure, actually.
If I'm
gonna keep throwing hard questions at you. We
could look this stuff up. It's
I think that's pretty normal.
If I mutate
the object
does it rerun all the others because the
state has changed or does it continue from
where that happened?
Do you know that?
I believe it continues from where it left
off in the life cycle.
So it just continue going as like one
big pipeline, like end to end. Like a
middleware layer of some Yeah, exactly. Yeah, like
a middleware layer of some kind, yeah.
So essentially you would want to order these
so that you have your,
the
thing that you want.
If you require any specific ordering and if
ordering is possible,
that you have ordering
in the sense that if something in the
last in the order relies on something from
the first, then you specify in that way.
Alright. Well, I think the
end of that will come out as we
actually apply to our cluster. So we do
have a go binary right now
which I expect to fail because of those
serps.
That's right. Okay. Well, did nothing.
Alright. We'll fix that in a minute.
Now we want to provision certificates,
build an image, deploy it to Kubernetes.
Yeah. That's right.
So
what we want to do is essentially
give Kubernetes everything it needs to get this
up and running.
So why don't we create a folder
with some manifests?
And then we can
start creating
an image
and getting that applied. Actually, we should probably
first create an image,
a Docker image.
So I imagine we're probably going to want
a Docker file.
So we set our working directory, we copy
everything to it, we run a go build
that should give us a binary and I'm
not gonna worry about adding like a smaller
image and stuff like that. We happy just
to deploy this one as is.
Yeah. Absolutely. So Kubernetes,
semantic
version.
Terrible name but we'll go with it. Yeah.
Let's go with that. So we should be
able to do an image belt.
Let's call this Rawkode.
We're not using semantic.
I'm just gonna take all the credit and
you know,
image sync. Absolutely.
We built this
and what did I get wrong?
Oh, it my get the Go image wrong?
That seem like a. It's
go Lang. Is it go Lang, yeah.
And we'll just do Alpine. Keep it as
small as we can.
There we go. That build should be pretty
quick. Pulling down our objects. Alright, let's tackle
a question about that build.
So okay, mods gave us a comment and
then a question. So why is auto complete
and not working? Have I got it disabled
and what Versus code theme am I using?
Autocomplete was not working because it was dead
load and dependencies in the background and then
it was failing to run some sort of
compile step or something. It seems to be
working now, so hopefully we're okay. I think
this is the plastic steam.
People always ask for teams, people love that
panda syntax. There we go. This is panda
syntax.
And then was had a question does a
certificate
or
should this certificate signed by the Kubernetes CA
or self same work fine?
Yeah. So we're gonna have to issue a
certificate that's signed by the Kubernetes CA. You
can provide a CA bundle,
but that will also need to be
that will be validated by Kubernetes itself. So
to avoid a little bit of faff, we
can I think it's best if we use
the Kubernetes CA, because that's already going be
automatically trusted
by Kubernetes itself?
Alright. So question time then for me this
time.
We're gonna write Kubernetes manifest to deploy this.
Yep. As the standard way for admission controllers
to have a deployment with replicas one, do
people use a straight up pod
or staple sets? Like, is the the facto
here?
Yeah. So
we'll create a deployment
and we're we you can have as many
replicas as you want.
So we could start with a replicas one.
But imagine if you want this to work
on a highly available manner, especially if it's
stateless
and idempotent,
then
essentially if one request fails, for example, because
the pod had died,
the mutation
hook itself,
then it would just reroute to another pod.
So yeah, just a standard Kubernetes deployment. And
we'll also have a Kubernetes service as well,
which is going to be fronting our
webhook.
And then gets the interesting bit, because we're
going to write a
mutating webhook
configuration.
Alright. Did that look okay?
Yeah. I think so.
Yeah.
Alright. Let's see if we can apply our
alt Kubernetes directory.
Lovely.
What did I build it wrong?
Yeah. I spelled it differently.
No.
Kubernetes context?
There
we go.
Let's reapply.
No
container. Okay. So we have an error but
we did deploy
successfully.
I think that's just because when we run
our
binary,
nothing happens.
And if we pull the logs,
it's just unable to open our certificates.
Yeah.
I'm
not quite sure why why it's not
why it's not running properly on your machine.
I don't know if it's actually erroring out.
But that's the the
the line there is what I expect.
Oh, wait.
Yeah. It runs successfully locally.
Interesting.
Could you try running it again? I'm just
gonna go build
on the local machine. Oh. There we are.
That's I don't think we had the latest
binary
built on the local site.
Classic.
Cool. So we are going to have to
inject
in these
certs.
And in order to generate them from the
first place, we going to use a tool
called
CFSSL.
So this is a set of tools that
Cloudflare have provided,
where it allows you to specify
a certificate
configuration in JSON format.
And
sidesteps the need for open SSL.
I can never ever remember the syntax for
open SSL. I always have to Google it.
It's really obscure.
Whereas with CFSL, at least you can reason
about what you've generated.
So let's go and create that. So we're
gonna generate a certificate signing request.
So
maybe if I create a new directory
in here,
Do you have a CFSSL
installed and also CFSSL
JSON?
Suppose so Well, I I just installed CFSSL.
Do I need to install another package?
Yeah. You'll also need CFSSL
JSON.
No dash,
I think.
Let's try do that. Does it come by
default maybe?
I'm not sure. Let's find out. So we
wanna generate a CSR.
So if we do
CFSSL
JSON,
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
specify the CSR in
JSON as in c f s s r
JSON as in one command.
Oh, one command.
Yep.
It probably might
come by default.
Oh, it does. There we go. I don't
know if my because I've not reloaded my
shells, I'm not getting auto complete on the
commands, but it is there. Okay.
Cool.
So if we go back to the editor,
I'll show you what the CSR
looks like.
So essentially
and I am
copying and pasting a little here.
Essentially,
what we're going to do What should I
be looking at here? Sorry.
I've
created a new directory with And
then there's a file called CSR. Json.
So what we have here is the
declaration of the CSR that we're going to
create. So what did we call the Kubernetes
service? Was it semantic? Semantic, yeah. Yeah. Okay,
cool.
Semantic.
And essentially, we allow
listing
those particular hosts
as part of the certificate signing request.
That's going to be the common name.
And yeah, I think we have everything we
need to start generating the actual
certs themselves.
So what we're gonna do now is if
we do
SSL
JSON.
So if you cat your CSR
dot JSON
yep. And then pipe that into
oh, is that saved properly?
Hopefully I've just saved it. There we are.
Yeah. If you pipe that into
CFSSL
gen key,
because we're gonna have to generate a key
first.
And
you also need specify a dash. And then
we're gonna pipe that into CFSSL
JSON
dash
bare,
b a r e, bare.
And we're gonna generate a server key.
So if you what did we call the
you're gonna need one more argument, which is
the the name of the the output file.
And what did we call it? We called
it webhook. So if you call that webhook,
that's just webhook. It will generate the the
required prefixes because it can generate two files.
Cool.
So that's now generated two files, hopefully. I
did. Webhook. C s r webhook key dot
pem.
Yeah. Great.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna
take the
certificate signing request, the CSR,
and we're gonna base 64 encode that, and
we're gonna create a
certificate signing request for Kubernetes.
Okay. So we want the CSR
Yep. Base 64.
So That's right. And if we we need
to create one more manifest which is the
certificate signing request
for Kubernetes itself. Yeah. I don't think I'm
gonna have a magic template for that.
So let's put that here and then let's
go find Kubernetes
CSR
YAML.
Let's
see if we got one here.
Some RBAC stuff.
And there we go.
So we want this base 64 included version.
As part of the request.
Do we need to modify
anything else within this?
Yes.
We're going to modify the metadata
to be the name of our
program,
semantic.
The name is going to be semantic.
We also want the signer to be the
kubelet itself,
the serving kubelet.
So that's going to be Kubernetes.io/kubelet-
serving.
Yeah.
And,
essentially, we want the mutating webhook to be
authenticated with the system itself because it's gonna
be interacting with Kubernetes
within the Kubernetes
certificate
framework.
Yeah. I think that looks good. So if
we apply that
we run get CSRs.
We have That's right. Yeah. So you have
a CSR that is pending.
And what we will need to do is
we can,
within kubectl,
approve it.
So if you do
kubectl
certificate
approve, I believe.
Certificate
approve.
Then the name of our certificate.
Amazing. Cool.
Now we'll need to extract out the
It says failed. The certificate.
Oh,
could you describe that?
Not particularly useful as far as debugging event
score.
No.
Interesting.
Yeah. There's nothing there.
I mean, the certificate does look valid to
me.
Oh, I think I wonder if we need
to add a few more usages because I
noticed that your your there's only one usage
there, which is client auth. Mhmm. I think
we need
KeyCypher
and digital signature as well. Okay. So just
delete the CSR and then we'll throw it
back. Yeah. If you delete the original CSR.
Let me see if I can add the
other two quick.
Just
make sure that's correct. So what I've done
is I've added the last two lines there
into the usages,
which is digital signature and key in Cypherment.
Now let's give that a shot.
Failed.
Let's see. What else do we have here?
Your request does look valid.
Let me just base 64 decode this.
Bay is a new lane or something.
Well, the certificate request looks valid to me.
Yep. Looks good.
Interesting.
This was gonna be a faff.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm nervous that Docker for Mac thing.
Maybe I shouldn't have skipped over this R
back stuff.
Well, no. Because I'm just root on this.
It doesn't
really matter.
Okay. Docker
for Mac CSR failed.
Let's see what Google tells me.
I think you do need to remove the
new line.
It might be a little bit picky.
I'm just looking at the Kubernetes documentation.
So when you base 64 encode it, if
you could pipe that into
t r dash d
and remove the new line.
Okay. So we want to cat the web
hook CSR but we want it to be
our dash d and then base encode.
I think we want to base so according
to this, it a base encodes first and
then
oh, actually then it's just removing the new
line. Yeah. From the b 64.
Okay. Maybe it's not that then.
I mean, let's see what does that do.
Well, you also need to specify delimiter.
So you want to specify
in quotation marks dash n. Yeah.
Oh, no. We don't want that. Yeah. Just
remove the new line.
There's a kill check from no base 64
dash w.
I'll look at that in a moment. I
think because I casted the CSR and base
encoded, I actually think that it should be
alright.
And normally if there was a new line
character and on the end you would see
a really familiar
like we'd see the two
equals with the padding and something.
Think that's Could you
possibly specify
in the metadata?
This is a long shot in the metadata,
specify a namespace. So if you do semantic
and what namespace are you in default?
I
think you need to specify that in the
name. So if it would just be semantic
dot default.
This is really much a long shot.
Let's give this a shot. We like long
shots. Alright. Let's delete CSR semantic because you
failed.
Let's reapply
all Kubernetes.
Let's get our CSR.
We can see it's pending.
Yep. Certificate
approved semantic.
Not default. Not default. Yeah.
And get CSR.
Oh no.
Alright. Let's see. What have we got in
our cube sys? I mean, there must be
logs on this. Right?
Yep. Likely. So
if we get the logs on the API
server.
No. I'm not sure what would be responsible
for this here.
Yeah. Don't think there's anything useful there.
Let's try controller manager.
Nothing useful here either.
Let me give this a shot on a
local.
Okay.
Let's try Kubernetes
admission
controllers
CSR.
I'll just Google random stuff just now. Let's
see what happens.
Oh, I think the signer is wrong.
Is it kubelet server client kubelet?
Or no, you said serving something. Right?
Yeah. Kubelet
dash serving.
Yeah. That does look okay.
Yeah. Do we have system modes? Organizations
are exactly system modes.
Common name starts with system
node.
Did we get that correct?
So our common name is
let's just make sure that our CSR is
correct.
Semantic.default.service.
Semantic Default
Service Cluster Local. That's fine.
System node
I wonder if that's different on Docker for
Mac.
Oh, possibly.
Ricky suggests we just restart my computer.
Maybe not today.
Yeah. I wonder if the docker for Mac
as
cluster DNS is different.
Let's
jump into
this doesn't work because it's
a funny
distro list or something.
Let's try.
Yeah. It's not gonna work.
How can I get the full
thing? Let's go.
Let's run something. I'm just gonna get a
debug container in here somewhere. So Yep. Like
a busy box or something. Yeah. Something I
can do a DNS lookup.
I'm not sure if there's a quick way
to get the actual
cluster DNS name. So and from Docker from
Mac at least.
Let's just run
a bit to
20.
Whatever
Ubuntu gives me by default.
And then my old favorite
sleep
args
infinity.
Alright.
Get pods.
Should've maybe have picked a smaller container image.
There we go. It's running. So
let's get inside of this.
Run bash.
Curl?
W get?
Tech? Alright.
Install
Baint tools.
I can never remember the name of the
Bain package. Bain tools, DNS utils, DNS tools
is one of them though.
Yeah.
I
guess I can just do curl. It's not
really that important.
So we wanna confirm So what's your current
theory at the moment?
That Kubernetes
dot default
dot cluster dot local won't work.
Default
dot s p c dot cluster
local.
If that was DNS, it would probably fail
for another reason. Right? No.
NS
tools.
Details.
Vague details.
Oh of course.
By nine. Yep.
Okay. Maybe on.
It should I
wish that package name was just consistent across
every distro but I seem to fight with
it every single time.
Eight
twenty seven,
that's annoying but
alright. Dig Kubernetes.
Default.
Svc.
Really?
Ubuntu take
command package.
I wish I could say that's the first
time I've googled that.
Banger Tails. Did I not try Banger Tails?
Did I try everything
but it?
And it doesn't stall that. Do I have
NS lookup?
Big.
I can't believe this is what I'm now
feeling on.
DNS utils. DNS utils.
Seven has asked if I'm on an m
one. I'm not on an m one.
Unfortunately not.
Yeah. So that's I think seven's confirming my
hypothesis is that the cluster DNS is actually
different. They're suggesting doc or dot internal. So
I just want to confirm that. So Kubernetes
default SVT.
Dot cluster.
That
does the result actually.
Interesting.
Could we have a quick look at the
could you describe the the CSR again?
Semantic
dot
default. Right?
The CSR
name should be semantic dot default.
Yeah. But that system node at the start,
what is that? Because that doesn't look like
a valid common name to me.
Is that wrong?
I
so according to the documentation, that is what
it should be.
The common name should start with system colon
node,
and then it should have a colon
with the name of your your full common
name.
So
name starts with system colon node colon.
Yep.
So the organization needs to be exactly system
nodes,
which we have.
Yeah.
I wish there was The certificate signing request
looks correct to me as well.
Yeah. So the cube controller manager does handle
this.
Let's try the logs again.
Logs cube controller manager.
Nothing there.
So
what I've done is I've generated a new
a new certificate signing request,
like a an absolute long shot.
Well, that's the face we got from Moz.
He says regenerate the CSR. So let's do
Exactly.
Now that's going to generate a new base
encoding.
Yeah.
And what we're gonna do there is
let's remove the original object from Kubernetes
and recreate it.
Okay. So delete. So it's our semantic.
It's gone. Yep. And default.
No. That that one failed with an error.
Yep. Can we just check to make sure
it's still not there?
Perfect.
Yep. All good.
So now we want to cat our
CSR.
Yeah. I've called it.
No.
I've already done that. So I've called it
server.CSR
this time.
Previously recorded webhook, but I called it server.
So, yeah, if you copy the base 64
What was that thing we got dash w
zero?
No. I think that command should be correct
with the t r.
That will remove the new line. And then
we can if you pipe that into p
b copy,
that will copy onto your clipboard.
Yeah. Okay. That's it. And
if we go to search.yaml
and put that into the the request.
K.
Has that been put in? Yeah. I don't
think it changed which means that it's probably
the same.
No. I don't I don't think it should
be. It would have generated with a new
key and a new algorithm. Right. Well, it's
maybe just something in the middle that's changed
and the end is
consistent. So let's try applying it.
So what I've done is I've just taken
the output from the terminal and copied and
pasted it myself, and it definitely changed.
Weird.
Interesting.
Let's try and apply the
I hope it will work.
Oh. 10 block type must be certificate request.
That's just come out there.
Into base 64.
Yeah. That's a certificate signing request. That is
a pen request.
Correct.
To do this kind of Oh, yeah. After
Kubernetes.
Yep.
The certificate spec
request
has invalid value.
That's really bizarre.
Maybe
you're right. Maybe it didn't change. Yeah. That
seems better. Cool. That's now created it.
I'm wondering whether we truncate in the new
line didn't work properly as as I'd expected.
Now let's try and approve it.
Alright. That's long shot.
Approved.
Oh,
no.
Okay. I don't know if this is a
Docker for desktop thing.
Let's let's let's change clusters. Right? I have
other clusters available. So
You have a mini cube cluster?
Yeah. We can create one pretty quick.
I also have a fully fledged nine nodes
cluster on Equinix metal that we can always
resort to have to do it.
Oh, that'd be great.
Maybe slightly overkill for building the mutation webhook
but would be fun regardless.
Let's see what many cube gives us in.
We'll just apply this entire certificate thing right
over the top approve it and I bet
you magically it's just gonna work and this
is some weird
Docker for Mac thing.
Yeah. I can't think what else it is.
What we have looks like what's in the
Kubernetes documentation so let's Exactly.
Okay. Come on, minikip.
While
you're getting that up and running, I'm gonna
try and see if I can get
Alright. So if I run get nodes, I
just wanna make sure we're on Medikube. We
are
let's apply.
I should be able to run get CSR.
Are you running the latest Kubernetes
on mini cube? It was running one eighteen
four. Do we need one twenty?
I think we'll need one twenty. Yeah.
Alright. Let's turn that down.
Start
Kubernetes
version.
Alright. I'll just take another moment.
The image isn't too big.
What version were you using on your Docker?
Was it one twenty as well? It was.
Yeah.
So according to
this random post I found on the Docker
forum,
always to be trusted. Right?
It seems it wants the signer to be
suffixed with docker dash desktop.
So as a weird Docker for Mac thing
then.
Yeah, possibly.
Alright. Well the only thing that changes now
anyway is we just have to rebuild the
image using the many cube context.
Other than that we should hopefully once this
spins up,
we're back on track. Fingers crossed.
Cool.
Almost foiled by certificates.
It's just the way it goes.
I did mention at the beginning that it
would be a bit of a fad.
So once we have these certificates, essentially
we'll have everything in place for Kubernetes to
interact with this webhook
and ready to intercept some requests.
Yeah. We've not even done the hard bit
yet. We've got a pars and resolve
that random semantic version thing I've thrown at
us.
It won't be that hard, I'm sure.
So there's a really great Go package that
I came across a couple of weeks back
called Semver,
which is really quite nice because you can
specify a semantic version
and specify,
like, grab a list of
other semantic versions and see if they match
and also sort them.
So essentially, you can say, oh, if you
have more than one dot 15,
and
then comma less than one dot 16, it'll
accept everything within that range but not 1.16
itself.
So everything above 1.15
but not 1.16 itself.
So it does all the hard work of
the stuff that we actually need to do.
Exactly, yeah.
It does all the hard work for us.
Yeah.
Oh, it failed.
Did that one fail as well? Yeah. I'm
gonna describe this other one that we have
in the mini cube cluster though.
What's different here?
The sign is different. Kube API server client
Kubler.
That's the only thing I can see that's
different.
Semantic dot default.
We added the dot default. I guess we
could always remove that. Right?
I think I know what the problem is.
In the usages,
the documentation says you need server auth and
we've got client auth.
So let's remove
client auth and change that to server auth.
I would hate for this to be the
issue.
Alright.
That's the least. Well,
you know,
these things are here to teach
us things. So
let's approve.
Yay.
Oh, dear.
Oh, no. Oh, well. Oh, no. Okay. Cool.
Right. We we we're we're back on track.
Do you wanna give that a very quick
shot with the docker version
as well?
Or would that be too much faff? No.
It's alright. Let's just pull it back to
Docker desktop.
Reapply. Because then we'll be able to avoid
the having to build the image into Minikube
itself.
Approved.
Oh, well, that's an old one. So let
me just Yeah. That's the old one, I
think.
Apply.
Approve.
Oops.
Go back the array amount of commands. Issued.
Yeah. Yeah.
Amazing.
Cool. So from there, what we need to
do is we need to extract out the
certificate itself,
the certificate authority
data. So we've approved the certificate.
And now we need to extract the CA
from Kubernetes itself to put into our
bundle.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to
put the command
just in the file that you're looking at
Mhmm.
For you to copy. Oh, you can just
type it into the terminal if you want.
Oh, yes. Actually, yeah. That would be good.
A weird wraparound thing.
That
final pipe should be there. Right?
Yeah. That final pipe shouldn't be there.
It did a weird wraparound thing for me,
but
Okay,
cool. So this is the
certificate authority that's for your
Kubernetes cluster. And what we're going do is
we're going to reference that as our
CA bundle. So this gives us the last
thing that we need.
Our Kubernetes cluster now trusts that
certificate.
We've done all of that.
This is the last bit that we need
on our side.
So that's So am I just copying this
and then creating a secret of it?
So
yeah. What you're doing is you're you're grabbing
that and you're creating your base 64 decoding
that as well.
So we need to base 64 decode that.
So why do we need this? Because this
is already in the cluster. Right?
Yeah. So this is the certificate
authority that has signed
the request. So we're gonna have to put
this into,
where do we need to put this? We
need to put this into the webhook itself.
So we basically, we need to specify the
certificate authority bundle
that has trusted our
webhook
certificate. So imagine it like this, right? Imagine
that we didn't use the Kubernetes CA to
issue the certificate for our webhook.
We need to tell Kubernetes,
where do you go look up the
authority
for that certificate itself? So you can specify
that as part of your configuration.
So one other piece that we need to
create is a mutating webhook configuration,
which is,
hey, Kubernetes, go and inject this webhook into
my cluster
and be ready to start calling it.
So maybe why don't we create that first
and then hopefully this will make sense why
this is necessary.
Okay. So let's create admission.YAML.
That's right.
And what
it is is
it's gonna require a little bit of boilerplate.
If you look for mutating webhook configuration
Let's see if we've got one here for
kind.
Nope.
If not, then I can get us started
with the boilerplate
that I have on my end.
If that's easier. That's weird. Yeah. If you've
got it there, we can just do that.
Don't know why my YAML search didn't work
there.
Cool.
So we've got an admission.YAML.
So essentially, what we're doing is we're starting
with the mutating webhook configuration.
We need to give it a name, like
all Kubernetes
resources.
So we're gonna call this semantic,
just to keep things consistent.
We don't need a label, I don't think.
Yeah, from there,
webhook itself.
Now, this is going to be the name
of the service
that needs to be called. So for us,
that's going be semantic.fault.service.cluster.local.
Does that look right to you? That is
right. Yep.
Cool.
We're also going to need some rules. So
essentially, we need to tell Kubernetes when this
when should this webhook be called.
Like what kind of operations are we watching
for?
What kind of resources are we watching for?
What API versions?
So here I have just pasted a set
of rules for
we're watching for the creation of pods.
And the good thing about this is that
it's not going to look for just manual
creation as well. Like if another controller is
creating pods, it will also pass through
appropriately.
I mentioned earlier that we want to specify,
like, a failure policy.
So what happens if the mutating webhook fails?
Like, you know, for example, the the webhook
doesn't exist
or, like, whatever.
Now, default policy is to fail,
which means that
our cluster will
essentially error out and say that we couldn't
call the webhook.
I have now failed the creation of the
pod. We probably don't want that from the
get go. So we're going to start with
ignore.
So what this will mean is that it
will try and call our webhook as like
a best effort thing. If an error is
returned or a failure happens during the call,
it will just ignore that and move on.
Now, the other thing that we need, lastly,
is a client configuration.
So this is the configuration for
how our webhook should be called.
I mentioned that
we
need to provide the endpoint and the port.
So we need to provide the service itself.
We need to provide the path and the
port.
So essentially, because we've specified a mutate endpoint,
we're
going to pass in that mutate endpoint there
and port four forty three.
And we also need to provide the name
of service as well. So the
name is going to be semantic. Now,
I mentioned earlier that we're going to need
the certificate authority itself.
That's also part of the
client config.
So
when you copy the certificate authority data of
your cluster, that's where it goes, the base
64 encoded version.
And that essentially lets it know what certificate
chain it should be looking for. And because
we're using the certificate authority of Kubernetes
CA,
we need to paste in that chain here
to let it know that that's the certificate
authority it should be using. Alright. Got it.
To validate our cert. So do
you have that copied? Could you paste that
in there?
I'm gonna copy it again just in case.
So oh, yeah. Didn't run the command. There
we go. So that should be it there.
Cool.
What was I complaining about there? Missing property
namespace. Oh, I wonder if we need to
find namespace as well.
Oh.
Says this must require entry side effects.
Effects, yeah. So
when you're creating a mutating webhook,
essentially you can specify whether your
webhook is going to create any sort of
side effects. So is it going to interact
with anything that's not been passed in?
Now for us, because we're taking in actual
pod that's being created and just mutating that
as part of our patch, our program has
no side effects.
So we're going to say side effects,
none.
Now, admission review versions. This is quite an
interesting field. So
right now, what we have is we have
resources
that are specified
as part of our API versions, like v1
pods.
Now, when Kubernetes came out, a lot of
these resources, like deployments and replica sets, were
in alpha one, beta one,
beta v1.
What admission
review versions does is that it will cast
older and newer versions into the version that
you are requesting.
Now because
pods
is currently v one and we want it
to remain v
Essentially we're gonna say admission review versions just
v one.
Does that make sense? Yeah. I think so.
Can I just check with you? Are you
okay to keep going? Cause I know that
our session was supposed to end around now.
So if you're available, we can keep going.
If not, we can always schedule a part
two. What works for you?
I'm totally fine to keep going. Yeah. As
long as you're okay with that. Yep. Perfect.
Cool.
It would be nice to get this mutating
webhook up and running and then we can
possibly leave the semantic clip for part two
or whatever works.
Cool.
So that is all we need for this
particular resource.
So let's try and apply that.
Alright.
So I'll just do admission.
That is now created.
Cool. Now if you fetch
that resource
Oh, mute it in.
Describe it?
Yeah. If you describe it. I I don't
think it's gonna be very informative.
Essentially that's now created our webhook and our
service will now be called
each time. Now I think the last thing
we need to do is just to set
up our secret so that we are injecting
in the certificates
for our
pod.
And then we should be good to go.
Then the whole life cycle should be up
and running.
Okay. So what we want to do is
add a volume.
Yep.
No, don't all complete that.
We want
secret.
Let's see if I can get nope. That's
not it. What
am I doing? Defining a volume. Right? Okay.
So Yeah. You're defining a volume and that
volume will probably be injected from a Kubernetes
secret.
Yeah.
I don't know why
that's not what it offered me a second
ago. There we go.
And the secret name, so
We'll just call it as semantic
cause we haven't created a sequence yet. Oh,
haven't created it yet. Semantic. And
we're just going to take everything and then
we want to add a
well, this is my debug one as well.
Let's copy that. Oh, yeah. I think you're
in the debug manifest.
And then we want to add volume
mounts where we mount our
semantic
no, certs.
Certs. Yep.
And we wanna put that in slash certs
in the root directory.
Done.
Sweet.
And we also need to create the secret
itself.
Yep.
I call it semantic.
And now we need our certificate.
Yeah. So we're gonna have two things here.
We're going to have the
key itself,
and we're also going to have the
what else do we need?
Cert.
We need the cert itself. Yeah, we need
to extract the cert from
Kubernetes.
How do we do that? I did have
that command safe as well.
Grab the cert from
the CSR. So let's get the key in
first.
So the key is going to be
webhook dot what do we call the binary?
In the binary,
we call it
webhook dash key dot m.
So what am I doing? Sorry.
So
what you're doing in
the data
is
where it says key, you're probably going to
want to rename that to webhook-key.pan.
Yep.
Got it. Yep. And then that's going to
be a base 64 of the
server-key.pan
in your in your root directory.
All
right, next.
Cool.
And we also need to grab the certificate
from Kubernetes itself. So we submitted a certificate
signing request. We now need to go and
fetch the certificate itself.
So if you do kubectl
get
CSR and then
semantic dot default,
you will need to
yeah. Actually, I wonder if it does come
in yeah. There we are. Certificate. So if
you just copy all of that,
that will be our certificate itself.
Amazing.
You think Kubernetes would provide a slightly easier
way to access the certificate signed with its
own CA system just to, you know, instead
of extracting out creating a secret where I
could just say, hey, pass this through to
testing but that I'll run a bit, maybe
we can wrap it earlier.
Okay, so we now have a secret.
These names have to match what we have
in our main dot go which were
webhook.crt
webhook - key Pem and webhook.crt.
Amazing. Which means
if I don't mess it up and do
an apply of everything this time,
I guess we can just do the deployment
that should create our secret update or deployment
with the volume notes and we should see
our new pod scheduled
and it is running.
Oh, amazing.
One thing we didn't do is we didn't
add any sort of logging to bug plants.
We're not going to know if
our mutation function gets called. So let's do
that very quickly.
So
Oh.
Very, very fancy. Yeah.
I'm a serial print line debugger.
I very rarely step into like GDB or
like any sort of like code dev or
anything like that.
It's done me well so far. Yeah. I
resort to print debugging and then I'll cave
and jump to a debugger if I feel
that I'm wasting too much time like when
I start doing I am here 76.
I'm like okay maybe I should get a
little bit more sophisticated there and I lie,
I never do. I am here seven to
six. Put swear words and it's Oh yes.
Yeah. I am I am the speller debugger
for sure.
Alright. So we built that image.
All we need to do is delete our
pod and what we should see now is
if we run logs and create a new
pod that is called, right?
That's right. So if we maybe
just, know, kubectl create pod with like NGINX
or something,
we should expect for
it to be called. Yeah. I'll just pop
in here. I'm just gonna make a chain.
In fact, no. Because this works in the
pod and not deployment level, right? I should
be able to just delete the debug pod
which will get recreated.
Yes.
If was tied to a deployment.
Ah, lovely. Amazing.
It all works. That means all of our
certificates are correct as well,
which is great. I don't think we need
any more certificate debugging for the rest of
the stream. Alright cool.
This means that the like
end to end chain works.
I think
how
far do you want to go? We could
get all of this up and running and
now it's just pure writing code.
Well, why don't we, if you're happy to
work till on the hour that gives us
around twenty minutes to hack together something with
the semantic version and you know, I don't
think we need to show a complete end
to end. We can, you know, we just
want to know show how we iterate on
this. We work with a client go We'll
do a little bit of that and then
maybe we can finish it offline and push
it to get up for people to to
kind of play with in their own time.
Cool. Amazing. That sounds good. Sweet.
So rapid coding.
I will try and talk through
all of the bits that we are doing
in really rapid fashion. So essentially, what we
have when we last left off this code
is we've got an admission review. Now if
we have a quick look into that admission
review itself, if you click through to the
admission review
oh, no. No. No. If you click through
to
oh, actually, well, yeah. There it works in
the in the Go docs as well. What
you get in the admission review,
if you command click on if you escape
that, if you command click on
line 15 where it says admission review,
yeah, it will take you to bit of
code. That's right. So what you have there
is an admission request,
and you are meant to specify admission response.
If you click through to the admission request
itself
oh, actually, yeah, it's just a few bits
down. What you have is you have
the UID of the request that's come in,
and you also have the object itself. Now
the object has a type of raw extension,
which is like
that might as well just say interface, like
Go interface.
Essentially, you can cast it to the type
of object that
you expect.
So we're going to unmarshal it into the
type of object we expect.
So essentially, what we want and what we
expect
from our mutating hook, the contract that we've
established with Kubernetes, is that it will send
us pod objects.
So we can try and unmarshal this into
a pod object. So
if you go back to the code itself,
what I'm doing is I'm initializing
a pod object.
And I'm going to try and JSON
dot
unmarsh
all of that.
Review
actually, that's going to be input
object.
Raw into the pod itself.
And
if that fails,
same deal here,
could not unmarshal pod.
So here, what we have right now is
the Kubernetes pod. We're probably going have to
add the import as well. So that's going
to be
API core v1.
Yeah, that's right.
Now
what we need to do now is
essentially try and figure out what images
are in the pod
to see if there are any images that
we want to semantically
modify.
So within the pod object itself, if we
click through to the pod object,
you have
the pod spec.
And within the pod spec, you have containers.
And within each of the containers, have a
container object.
And within each container object, have an image.
Does that make sense so far? Yep.
So
what we're going to do is we're going
to simply iterate through,
just like you would in
standard Go, if you have a slice of,
well, anything really.
Pod dot spec dot containers.
And
what we're going to say is,
let's say that we just want to take
that particular container and apply
any sort of patch to it.
I was
just going to suggest,
if we detect
or why don't we just replace it with
NGINX latest just to kind of show it
working? Does that make sense? Yeah. That's exactly
it. So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to create
a map
with our patches itself.
If
we had a bit more time, I'd probably
use a proper ghost struct.
And what we're going to say is,
patch equals
append
patch
map string string.
How I mentioned, similar to how you would
do a
Kubernetes style patch operation,
you have three fields. You have the operation
that you want to do. So here, what
we want is we want to replace the
image name.
You have the path,
which is the
name of the object itself that you want
to replace within the YAML. This starts at
the very top level. So just like you'd
have a JSON path,
you start the spec.
And then within the containers, you have a
list.
This is where the index comes in handy,
because we can inject the index in. And
we probably want to sprint off that
by the image field itself.
And what we want to do is we
want to set its value
to just NGINX latest.
Useful. Does that make sense so far? Yeah,
quite useful.
Yeah, I think we just need
assignment.
There.
Can't this is the patch Yeah.
So
we need to assign it to the patch
map. So that was a bug on my
And
we don't need the assignment there.
We have what we're doing now is we've
generated a list of mutations. What we're saying
is for every container that you see, replace
this image tag with NGINX latest.
Very, very helpful. And what we need to
do is we need to
wrap that up
into
a series of bytes.
Send response.
We'll
deal with that in a second.
Now,
like I mentioned earlier,
every single thing that we
work within admission controller is essentially an admission
review.
Yeah, thank you for correcting that. Is
an admission review object. So we're going to
generate a response,
which is our response review.
And that's an admission v one admission
review.
And that's going to be
we can copy the meta fields
from the input.
TypeMeta,
because we want the same output to go
out.
And the response is going to be an
admission v1.
Admission
response.
And within there,
the UID,
which is going to be input
do it.
But there's an interesting flag that you can
specify,
which is
with
the mutations that we've seen, or with the
input that we've seen, do we want to
allow this request to go through, or do
we want to deny it?
Now, we want this request to go through,
but with a series of
what we're saying here is, this request looked
fine to us,
but make a few tweaks, please, for us.
And you don't need to specify this, but
just for
niceties,
admission viewable.
JSON patch. If they add any support for
any other patch types,
So
we've now generated a response review. We need
to marshal that again.
That code, REST flights.
to head to oh, actually, similar to what
we have here.
And need
We need to that's going to be respite.
JSON. This is status Okay.
I've got some error handling to do here.
That just
Could not
generate patch.
And could
not
the rest view.
Could not
generate
very helpful error messages is here. Okay. So
let's have a very, very quick walk through
of
what we've done here.
Essentially,
we have taken in our input object, unmarshalled
it to a pod because that's exactly what
we expect.
We've generated a series of patches.
We have created
a response
set of patches.
We have wrapped that up into an admission
review
response object with a list of patches. And
we've told it that we want to allow
this but with a series of patches.
And we're now sending that off into the
wire.
I think it's important to note for people
watching, like the only thing that's really bespoke
and not boilerplate here is just the
patch that we want to apply to the
manifesto has come into our admission controller.
Everything else you can copy and paste pretty
much
character for character. You're a machine for typing
that out so quickly by the way, that
was awesome.
This is where your
magic happens, whatever modifications you want to make
within your controller,
this is the secret sauce here and this
is JSON patch format, you can Google that,
there's different types of operations and ways to
work with it and I know it looks
a little weird at first sight but you
do get familiar with it over time.
Now this is obviously the most useless contrived
example that we've put together but we could
build this now and regardless of what we
apply to our cluster
is gonna overwrite it with the NGINX image
and what we need to be careful with
when we deploy this is that none of
our system pods or anything like get deleted.
Yeah and same with the
hook itself.
Yeah.
That'll be fun. Alright. Let's rebuild our image.
We'll delete our pod. We'll let that come
back up and then we will make a
change to our
debug pod and we should see that image
change from the Ubuntu one that we used
earlier
to NGINX.
That's right.
I'll just give Google a little second here.
I guess we are pulling in a few
extra dependencies now as well.
Yeah. The core v one has got to
put in a lot of Kubernetes.
So if I run get pods,
we can delete
pod semantic.
So that's gonna get the new version of
our mutating webhook.
What I'll also do is just pull up
the logs for that here.
Let's see if we get the new one.
We do. Excellent. And
just to show, let's describe our debug pod.
We can see here that the image is
it been too.
So assuming I've not got my understanding incorrect
here, when I delete this, a new create
pod is going to be initiated and the
image should be changed. Right? That's what we
expect. That's
That's what we expect. Yep.
Alright. Let's see.
So delete delete. I don't need to wait
for that. I'm just going to go straight
into describe. We should get a new ID
here.
FC.
And
it works. Oh yes.
Success.
We now have a mutating web hook admission
controller
making modifications to every pod
and in real time as they had our
Kubernetes cluster. That is awesome.
Yep. Not useful but very much awesome. And
I wonder if that sleep command is even
gonna work. It has. Right. Okay. It's quite
happy. NGINX is probably based on up into
anyway. So
awesome. Cool.
What do want to do then? Do you
want to pull in the Semver library and
see how that works? Do you want to
pause it here and resume another day? How
are you feeling?
Alright. So we've got ten more minutes till
the top of the hour and let's see
how quickly we can get the December
up and running. Alright. Take a look. So
there is if you pull up the
Chrome window,
sorry, browser window, and we see
the library I mentioned earlier is called mastermind
slash semver.
Let's give that a shot.
So, yeah, this is a library that allows
us to
essentially process
semantic versions.
And what we're gonna do is we're gonna
use that and call out to
I imagine we want to call out to
Docker Hub to see what tags are available
and see if we can do some sort
of
reconciling
with the two.
So let's try and get that running as
quickly as possible. Let's cheat,
right?
Because we don't need to reach the docker.
I mean we can definitely do that but
I don't think are we gonna be able
to make that in ten minutes? I I
don't think so.
Fair enough. I mean are you feeling brave
again? You're the one doing most of the
coding here. I was just gonna suggest that
we just provide an arbitrary list of versions
and have it work against it but I
will
I'll let you go. Yeah. Alright. Let let
let's go with that. Let's go with that.
Let let's make it easy for ourselves. I
think we've had enough difficulties as it is.
So yeah.
Well I think for me the important bit
is seeing how this amount of version thing
will work rather than you know, an HTTP
request at Docker Hub. I'm happy to you
know, we can do that offline or whatever
But
Yeah.
See. Let's just
make a go for it. Let's see what
happens.
If I just pull up the NGINX
versions on Docker Hub,
a few examples in there are actually valid
images
that are going to be pulled.
So we
have one dot 15 onwards.
One dot 15
one dot nineteen dot six.
Yeah. One dot
nineteen dot six.
One 18 zero.
And let's get one more just to give
us a bit of
wiggle room.
Let's go back a bit.
One seventeen four.
Hey, we've got plenty of options here. So
like we can set our constraints now. Yeah.
Exactly.
Cool, amazing. So what we're going to do
is
that should
be good enough. So what we're going to
do is we're going to take the image
tag that's come in, do some string manipulation
to get the constraints there,
and then
use that
to figure out what version is best.
So
a little bit
messy, but we're going to do all of
that in this particular for loop.
Now
what we want to do is,
let's see,
import the library first. That'll be quite good.
Yeah. And I'll prepare an example. So let's
assume we can satisfy
I guess we wanna Do you have a
terminal on your end? My terminal seems to
have
Alright. It's because it's running the logs.
I see.
Could you go get the
Semva package?
Cool. Amazing. So what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take our
image name,
which is going to be
container.
Yeah. Container
image.
I'm going spit it on the colon.
And we're going to want two parts.
And
the
image name is going to be on the
left.
It's
a bit on zero.
And the
version constraint
is going to be on the right.
And what we're going to do is we're
going to
I've copied an example actually from
there.
We'll use what they can already parse, so
we don't need to.
Amazing.
So that's going to be version constraint.
So this new constraint is going to give
us a
auto complete is still loading.
New constraint returns a constraints instance that a
version instance can be checked against. So essentially,
what we're doing is we're passing in the
range to the new constraint. And then we
will iterate
through the list of our versions and see
which ones satisfy.
Yeah, That's done.
So what we want to do is for
version in version range
versions.
More errors for now. Don't do this in
production, folks.
Test version
as a string.
What we're gonna do is
Do we need to look the versions? Does
that not take a list and return the
best one? Does that know how the library
works?
I don't think it provides a function for
that
version.
No. It wants you to iterate through them.
Alright. Okay. So
what we're going to do is send for
new version,
which is our version.
And what we're going to do is we're
going to say,
if
v
actually, if hook constraint
matches,
I think, is the name of the
of
the check. Oh, there we are. Yes, check.
So what this is saying is, does
our version in our version list match our
constraint?
V.
Then we're going to say best version equals
version.
So far
and then
over here, instead of using NGINX latest
Spring.
F.
I
nginx
spring
best version.
Cool.
I think this should be what is required.
So what we're doing here is we're taking
the image name from Kubernetes as it's passed
in,
splitting at the semi colon
I'm sorry, at standard colon,
initializing our constraint from there.
Yeah. Thank you for that.
We're iterating through our version list,
checking which ones match the constraint. And the
one which is the
most latest, assuming that this is an ordered
list
that matches, will be put into the best
version
string variable. And then we're now interpolating
that into our value.
So let's
give this a shot. Do you think we
should very quickly
just not do anything if we get an
error?
Yeah.
We can probably just send an error out.
So
yeah, if you add one there.
I'm just thinking like if we wanna confirm
that this works.
I mean, we're about to redeploy this controller
which is already gonna
break it potentially.
No. Because we have the allowed failure. Okay.
Maybe maybe we'll be okay.
Oops.
Return.
Alright. Let's build this. Let's do it. Yeah.
We're gonna
happy?
Yeah. I think so. I just changed the
error to output it to standard out. I'm
sorry, output it to response.
Okay.
So we're gonna build this,
redeploy
it
and then in theory we're gonna try and
add our constraints to our debug container which
should be resolved for us. All with thirty
seconds left. If
this works first time around then that's it.
It's like mic drop off. Yeah. That's it.
Just
walk away with like job done. Mhmm. Yeah.
Very impressive.
Okay.
Delete
pod semantic.
So now we have a new version of
our mutating admission controller running
hopefully.
Yep.
So let's,
the reason I wanted this here is what
I was going to suggest is we have
this debug thing being deployed. Right? Let's take
a look at that,
which right now is just using this. There's
no colon. So I just wanted it to,
you know, it can't powers it just to
continue.
So now we can add
20.04
and that should still fill which means it
should just go untouched I would imagine.
Do you agree with that? Hopefully.
Possibly.
So we can describe our pod which is
this new one here
and it should be untouched.
Correct. Awesome. Yes. Correct. Now we want to
apply our magic syntax where we say NGINX
and
we're gonna say greater than 1.16
less than or equal to 1.17.
Which should require I think I need a
comma there.
No. We don't have a one sixteen. Okay.
I need to go up to one eighteen.
What should give us one seventeen four. So
Yep. You're gonna need a comma in your
yeah.
Between
so more than equal to one sixteen comma
less than equal to one eighteen.
That wasn't an example.
Yeah. You can just do Oh, actually, yeah.
Maybe you're right.
Okay.
That's right. That should work.
Right. I've never been so nervous.
Container creating. Alright.
Okay. Let's see what happened.
Okay. So we didn't parse this.
Could you try with the with the comma?
So you want the comma here?
Yeah. And also could you remove the space
after the after the colon?
You happy with that? Yeah.
Let's let's try that.
Okay. I think we're gonna need to quickly
pull out some logs.
Yeah. Nothing to replace.
Let's try
semantic.
I don't think we have much going on
there yet, do we? Okay.
You got five minutes to debug? Will we
go for it? Yes.
So is our semantic
program running
properly?
As in, is mutating webhook running properly?
Because that looks wrong to me
when you put in the logs of the
semantic.
Wonder if it's running engine neck. Yeah.
Describe. That would be terrible.
Yep.
Oops.
Okay. So we should be able to delete
that now.
Yeah. The latest version, no.
So I actually did so this will work
but for a reason that is that's quite
interesting. The webhook will fail because, you know,
NGINX is providing garbage.
And what it will do is it will
just fall back and ignore the error,
whereas previously the semantic hook was
correctly functioning.
So if you describe the semantic pod now,
it will
it should be running with the correct thing.
I think that's pulling a new NGINX. I
think it's worked.
Can you describe it? It has.
Oh, yes.
And
it resolved.
Success.
Amazing.
That Siri celebrating?
That is Siri celebrating
with us. Alright. That was awesome.
So you know,
let's talk about what the next steps are.
Let's finish up. Thank you very much for
pretty much writing this entire thing and that
was really cool to see that from start
to finish.
So let's assume I really want this to
be a thing, right? So we wanna take
this code, we wanna productionize obviously we should
add tests and how do we
ensure that we don't run into that problem
we have
with the semantic controller. I guess we have
to build checks
and constraints into this loop here, right? Yeah,
exactly. So
the within the mutating webhook in Kubernetes itself,
you only have namespace level
constraints
being added. So
saying, don't call this webhook if the namespace
matches these particular labels. So for example, we
could add constraints that say, don't run this
for cube system.
And we could put the semantic program itself
in its own namespace, and also say, don't
run this if
in these particular namespaces, or have these labels,
or whatever.
We will probably want to add checks within
this program itself
to state that
if the version doesn't look like a constraint
range,
then just continue onwards. Like, be graceful
in that respect. And yeah, like adding tests
and stuff like that.
The good thing about this is that this
is a standard
Kubernetes
API program. So there's no reason why you
can't generate some mocks
and
interject them as like a HTTP,
using HTTP mocking library in Go,
yeah, you just pass these objects across. It's
just JSON at the end of the day.
You don't need any sort of Kubernetes
framework or anything like that to test this,
which is great. Nice.
Because we are operating on a pod level
as well, we'd probably want to cache those
resolutions I guess and memory
or even on disk somewhere because
as the pods are moved around or killed
or whatever, we don't want it to resolve
new versions for some pods and older versions
for other pods. We still got a few
things here that just make this a bit
more feasible but excited. Yeah. Very, very excited.
It it's also interesting because we may want
to want this to run on a replica
set level
instead of a pod level. So imagine that
you are
rolling out a a version
of your system, even if it is a
minor version, you probably don't want an upgrade
to be happening.
Like just because a node died, for example,
we might want to say, Okay, when you're
ready to roll out a new replica set
and you
do the kubectl
rollout restart,
that's the time it decides, or maybe I
should consider if a new version is available
that satisfies the constraints. Because then at least
it's human controllable.
At a pod level, it's probably too granular.
Yeah.
Awesome. Well,
I will push this code up just as
reference for anyone that has been watching and
playing along with us. I will speak to
you afterwards. We'll work out how to clean
this up, make a few tweaks hopefully publish
it for people to consume and test out.
Happy to see my world idea actually working.
Thank you so much for just being able
to explain everything that we were doing as
we go so well and for churning out
all of those code debugging
certificate nonsense everything there.
I think that was really valuable for me.
I'm sure it was very valuable for others.
Thank you very much for that.
Yeah, thank you everyone. No, this was was
really really fun.
Yeah and I hope this is useful. It's
a fantastic idea
and I really hope that we can actually
turn this into a proper plug in that
people
will use. Yeah definitely. Watch the space is
coming soon definitely. Yeah coming soon. Coming soon
to a Kubernetes cluster near you.
Alright have a great day again. Thank you
for allocating that extra time. I know we
went over and I'll speak to you again
soon and goodbye. Thanks. Yeah. Bye everyone.